thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys today we have every
single careful boy in the room
it's a wonderful day [__] merch all
right we're gonna settle we're gonna
settle this once and for all
wet Asian makes the hottest Asian guy I
already know that we're actually doing
this [__] I've been paid I've been
playing paying a close attention what
all right
Indonesians is that because Yoshi or so
so the seduction Brothers the dark soul
brothers are pretty fine good job yeah
they are fine but what I've noticed too
is Asians if we if Asians are just as
segregated as the whole world you know
what I'm talking about yep like what do
you mean like Jeremy land [__] was
crushing in NBA Koreans like [__] that
[__] he ain't Korean like we're
we're like to the outside world we're
we're we're actually we look like the
same but we're actually really
segregated and we probably got even more
beef internally that's so funny how we
get grouped up we group we get grouped
up into one group in America it's like
but it's it's just so far I don't know
how we made it work in America and then
if a Korean guy crushes it right but if
guy is like as egotistical the whole
time then a lot of the other is like man
this phone ain't even doing it for us
he's only doing it for this one what's
that have to do with the Indonesians
being honest I'm getting there yeah
we're trying to set the he's trying to
set how divided we are the vibe yeah
we're so divided right we got crazy a uh
East Asians really light-skinned looking
and slender like they've never seen the
sun then we got some dark ass
[__] that you're like are you
aborigine but you're still kind of Asian
and what I noticed is Indonesians are
right in the middle oh like Chinese
passing but they got the sultriness of a
Southeast Asian you know so they got so
so like you're kind of right like you
could like you take Yoshi sidarsa for
example right he's a well-rounded he
could be a K-pop Star yeah right yeah
but he could also be a Cambodian Village
man yeah and you kind of believe
everything that's true he plays Japanese
in movies exactly he does have a
Japanese his name he cannot be a K-pop
Star you're out of your [__] mind
[__] out of here really K-Pop Stars need
to look like they can kind of float a
little bit yes
brother so so he has yeah there's like
pixie interviews Western more
western-like features or like that he
has ones that blends at all he's
handsome features and I've noticed a lot
of Indonesians have handsome features
this guy could have a rose in his mouth
and not look gay yeah they have a lot of
like you know just look like Vega yeah
honestly Yoshi sadasa is the ideal Asian
man but a lot of Indonesians got that
look that they're like they could be
Korean men are crushing it right now
they are crushing it you know they're
definitely crushing it but I would say I
would argue that East Asian men are more
cute and Southeast Asian men are more
handsome that's what I would say all
right who would you rather [__] a
Southeast Asian man or East Asian man
East Asian man all the way see Peter
could be a a porn star
is not quite floating he's close though
he's Peter Pan s yeah but but he needs
to be lighter and younger yeah yeah he's
just a little too he needs to be
translucent [__] passionate video
right now dude as six straight guys okay
speak for yourself
minus Nick
when you look at a stereotypical Asian
dude from whatever country right which
one would you suck off the hardest yeah
that's a good question
which one do you look at and go oh he's
throbbing I'm ready to go but I'm
straight but if I was to suck then it
would have to be it's a hypothetical
yeah if I had to stop experience you
would suck super well remember yes I
would if I had but I I think I would
choose I don't really care about the
skin color I care about the penis color
oh the lighter skin the penis the
cleaner it looks to me for some reason
oh you're colorist man oh that's messing
your racism just comes out like crazy
maybe Korean or Japanese penis what
color is your penis
that's wrong dude because Korean a
Japanese penis we got purple dicks our
skin is translucent but our dick is dark
yeah like your soul a Southeast Asian
dick because it matches is yeah I'm
pretty sure Ryan's dick is tan just like
him imagine that's a TED Talk kind of
dark too yeah yeah so good we should do
this in front of an audience
my dick doesn't even look like it
belongs to me mine Singaporean guys you
think are the hottest Asians no I'm kind
of I'm kind of Bart made a really good
point I'm kind of on Indonesian well
it's hard because if you're thinking of
the sudarsos and yeah but you watch a
lot of their movies a lot of them look
like them like if you watch the Raid or
whatever A lot of them have like a very
like I do think oh they're like Melting
Pot of Asian like those guys are Thai
you know what I mean oh you like the
Thai guys the one that looks like ladies
I don't like them pale don't like them
pale there's a lot of the hottest people
in Thailand are pale though I like them
a little darker the ones that work in
the fields they got a dark undertone the
ones that don't have soft hands like a
gold skin you know you're talk you're
thinking about that [__] kickboxer
who bull cow bull cow he's dark dude you
like him
Thai guys
see they all try to look like Chinese
pop stars can I say something about this
this look the Asian male look whether
they look like uh very pale and they're
very like
um feminine looking uh-huh I'm not a fan
of no you don't like that okay I'll find
you one then I don't like that you wanna
you want a man to take control huh I
want a man dude you want a man to
dominate you huh when I watched Yoshi
siddharsa on TV I'm like that's a
leading man right there I'm like this
guy needs to be a more leading what
shows you know he's in bullet train yeah
he was he has his own cowboy movie on
Netflix I forgot the name I just I just
want to let you know that I had the
honor of rolling Jiu Jitsu with Yoshi
and he's a very strong dominant man
that's what I'm saying that's why I like
that yeah you like this type of dude yup
dude I don't like that pose this is
honestly a really bad post no it's just
a Filipino guy this is like yeah the
camera guy was gay the camera guy's like
hey give me this post what and and that
doesn't even look comfortable how do you
how do you look cool and sexy if you're
not comfortable you gotta think of it in
motion
that looks like a [__] scoliosis it's
like the best seat in the house I want
to know what Steve thinks and which one
it's not about Asians yeah I thought you
had an Asian preference what the
feminine looking why only fetishize that
yeah yeah I want the a uh the feminine
looking uh ones you want the floaty ones
you know what's funny is I've been
typing different like things like
Vietnamese hot guy Thai hot guy every
time I do it it always has to darso see
I'm telling you they're The Perfect
Blend um all across do you guys did you
do you remember that thing where uh they
were like the hottest Asian guys right
and then they would be in each culture
modern like old school culture [__] like
there'll be a guy in a [__] sandwich
yes that was great it was like a
Cambodian jelly representing the yeah I
was like dude it looked like some kind
of Asian ancient superhero [__] yeah it
was dope but
a lot of the guys look gay
you think you whisper dude
we heard that
he said it
was saying it like this okay because
here's the thing right like there is
they're like they're the I get it like
there's a beautiful look to it right but
then like but but here's the thing okay
as a straight guy that wants to be
represented I'm saying that already by
straight men I feel like I don't want
some uh I don't want a gay guy
to culturally appropriate straight
culture
[Laughter]
who is that the last Last Samurai yeah
dude that guy who is that guy oh you
know who that guy is you know who I have
a man crush on you know that Japanese
actor and Last Samurai knock him
Watanabe but his right hand man
I like that guy that was hot that guy's
he's my man crush is that a traditional
Japanese hot guy no that's the wrong guy
look at his face not that guy I thought
that was that one guy that's always in
the Wong foosh movie Harry show that's a
hat no not him
that's a half guy about Ryan which guy
the guy the right hand man to Kim
Watanabe and last summer I like him talk
about that guy
and like Marvel's Avengers a lot of [__]
everything everything
yeah I like him he's my man show the
world hiroyuki yeah yeah let me find a
thing when you think of the word [__] you
think of him honestly yeah yeah we're
all thinking of that word yeah yeah this
guy yeah he's cool that guy's pretty
badass he's a badass most of the guy in
the Mortal Kombat movie who played
scorpion that's it yeah that's him when
he played scorpion he's a bat is a
badass Mall because he's
all right let me ask you guys a question
all right that's the answer so so far
Indonesia's still in the lead Anthony
has an answer so like there's a little
there's a lot there's a little bit of
like clean cuteness and a lot of Asia
Asia Asian uh uh guys right yeah right
but like do you think out there they
like
rough masculine looks no probably not
because I think that was my mom's era
like their Stars their guys they look
more like like sexyama
but they like facial hair they like
bigger bodies
um hard bodies I actually think that's
the same across the world of that
generation you're like even here like
like who's hot right now like Harry
Styles right he looks like a woman any
dresses yeah exactly like like like in
sync like our generation
I thought they were all the words I
can't use
I thought they were all words I can't
use Maybe
maybe I'm thinking so like
so so there's
what teens find attractive right yeah
and then there's what women find
attractive there's what women finders
and this is what dudes fly distracted
too yeah that too what dude
why is he looking like that wow
now I think women and gay and the whole
world
would like that you can all come
together they can come together and come
on him
that's so true it was like a guy who
just got here like just came to America
and he's like trying to be cool but
everyone's like yeah women and gay
everybody this is inclusivity man
yeah well because I can't picture like a
13 year old girl liking uh Jason Momoa
because it's scary that's true yeah it's
intimidating and it's too old too
masculine I can see how she would like
um a grown-ass woman who needs a [__]
I could see like uh yeah like they would
like boyish looks because it's more
age-appropriate it's closer to them
whereas a guy I think they can be 12 and
[__] thirst for you know Carmen
Electra it's my arrow but you know what
I mean like they want a a woman woman
right yeah yeah true but I don't think
it's the same for girls no it's not yeah
that's why I don't think hip-hop stars
are so big because it is 12 13 year old
girls 13 exactly yeah for the Peter Pan
[__] yeah Peter panel for sure
but then also I'm like
yeah so who are the guys that women like
in Asia probably like the Scorpion dude
yeah scorpion I see
like who would be on the slightly older
and nowadays though you know what I mean
yeah then you might still want somebody
that doesn't look overly like this hat
looks like your father is like a couple
children I just elbow like an old dude
that's who's winning they just love him
who's that guy how dare you first of all
oh wait was it one of our editors
it's Justice what what Justice yeah it's
Justice
he does we do have editors who wear
earrings yeah I I don't remember his
name exactly but yeah
Jay how dare
do you feel it no I get it I see it but
to me obviously floating he's floating
100 this guy's 100 yeah you could fire
bullets at him
you like it oh yeah I make out what I'm
in a heartbeat if he's not difficult to
kiss yeah yeah you smell this he's hello
cases he's very pretty yeah those are
fuckables yeah it looks like the hygiene
is good and there's a lot of respectable
things that you be down you know what I
mean well better than some women
probably I bet the inside of his [__]
smells like a perfume bottle he looks
clean he's cleaned out like press his
foot and something nice will come out
[Laughter]
you know who's also handsome Bruce Lee
is very handsome very handsome very
handsome guy he got some White in them
too does he yeah yeah he does that's
right yeah
it looks dope yeah yeah yeah look at the
job charismatic dude he's like man he's
a Clooney he's a Clooney
people like him
dude
he's awesome when he was younger guys
like Tony lung all the hot the Hong Kong
actually young bro I mean Aaron clocks
all those those [__] are pretty
ass nice looking hot dudes you know um
remember Lethal Weapon four with Jet Li
uh well you know oh you're next to
Randall Park though that's different
yeah Randall Park for comparison he was
so scared he was tired but Asian guys
are confusing you know you look at their
face and you're like it's so cute and
you look at some of if they're all
finished in you're like but you got a
[__] man's man's body it feels like
you can [__] be sweet to me but also
nasty Daniel how did Kim get the Giga
Chad jaw like how did that happen he's
doing Facebook bro dude is that a Korean
trait Korean like some dudes are so
handsome this football probably got so
many teachers hitting on him growing up
as a kid sometimes you could do with
weights on your face yeah dude that you
just keep on going yeah I don't know but
look how I had some now the shape of
daily Kim's face is like of the world I
have a Daniel day camp kid pictures
I bet you he was like turning so many
teachers on and [__] that's true that's
what I'm saying he doesn't have a weak
jaw look how handsome that fool looks it
looks like if a chick's trying to kiss
him and she'll [__] her face up oh yeah
I should cut her face dude let's find it
duffel pie hit puberty was like four all
the photos of him look like hella old
still even his kid pictures
four-year-old with a goatee I bet he
doesn't have one person somebody doesn't
even have a kid like these [__]
[__] yeah dude I have at least three
percent these people look like you why
does it feels so good looking these guys
complimenting himself this guy
I mean that's what
that's the most kid photo I could find
of him so Indonesia and still in the
lead huh yep
but I don't know man Korean has that
freaking that she'll say this right now
I think Koreans are top G's right now
they're trending they're they're
definitely yeah as far as like America
like as a is a Korean which one I don't
know he just saw the 100 men you like
the boys
oh hey physical 100s are great but you
like the boyish looks are you like the
more manly look no I don't like boyish
looks bro the witch Korean you're
talking about I'm just saying I'm just
saying overall like people in America
the fact that like they're crushing it
they're crushing it yeah you know what I
mean they're all over Netflix they're I
think that's that's that says a lot
there you see they're everywhere
everything all I want I would say that
pony that's very Chinese actually you
don't like Tony jaw Tony jaw's good
looking dude does he is he the type
where you're just like I'll suck him off
you know what he doesn't not uh yeah
yeah
well but I I got a little nervous dude
I got a little nervous because uh the
answer is yes okay okay what about you
you think Tony you would suck that guy
off Tony ja uh NABA let him suck me off
you know you know in physical 100 that's
cool that old OG MMA fighter that
everybody's like bowing down to yeah
is sexy as [__] he's a model can you
find out can you find us as uh like a
Yoshi picture of him yeah you wanted me
to say something Steve what is this
[__] video bro
the whole time he finally opens up and
says this guy's sexy as [__] that's why
I'm laughing
I mean that's him now he's like older
and he still looks good look at that
dude
wow that's a sexy guy
but his eyes are yeah you know I like
darker skin rugged man's man like you
know how like gay dudes are all fit yeah
yeah I'm out I'm gonna say all but you
know how they're all fit yeah yeah but
there's like elements there's an element
that you're like hold on wait a minute
there's something gay about you yeah you
need a man who's gonna hunt for your
meat and then make you the Tomahawk
Steak on your [__] table but then
he's down to be a little spoon even
though he's buff oh that's cool like the
gay man you know what I mean
maybe it's because it's a gay
conversation
but do you think but do you think the
kind of guy that we're really into
is this yeah can we look for him yo
she's so dark so dude he's our guy Yoshi
you know he's married okay I agree yo
all right I like the little boy ones
though yeah yeah Yoshi's hot
I agree
but to me
he doesn't have enough facial hair give
me the BTS but he can grow it he can
grow it toss those guys around serve
them up Ryan has he just he just doesn't
go because it doesn't it doesn't work
for his role no no no he's too boyish
for me and you know what the other part
about it that I don't like he's my
friend and that that taints it like that
but also no I'm trying to [__] a friend
also I like a little bit of a dirty man
both of my [__] feet on their necks
and I wear shoes on my hands and I put
those [__]
he can take the whole crew all of BTS at
once I believe imagine Steve BTS member
a man should look like he smells like
rum and cigarettes and it looks like he
skips showers a day or two what about
the guy from physical 100 that everyone
kept saying was like Bart
[Laughter]
you're in the water right and you're
about to eat the fish and the whale eats
you like I got myself there's always
bigger fish in the sea eat up on the BTS
kid's head and I got my [__] hands up
like this and then this guy comes in
behind me there's one big shoe
that's the dude on the left that feels
big as [__] what is the shoulder on the
right though like what is that is that
not hot God yeah
yeah those guys are [__] buff I think
we all been missing the actual hottest
guy here kind of come on bro with that
alien though I [__] that guy yeah I
[__] that guy and I filed a police
report immediately
not myself dude for sure this guy's the
most hottest
[Laughter]
[Music]